each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so it's my pleasure today to welcome
Ryan mutant from MIT Ryan is finishing
his PhD there and is going to talk to us
about some work that is of great
interest to me because it combines both
programming languages and systems
research right thank you very much Jim
oh we do the speakers on here so hello
and good morning thanks for ringing out
and thanks for inviting me to speak
today I'm going to be talking to you
about the wave scope project which was
part of my thesis work at MIT and this
is a talk about a parallel and
distributed programming model but it's
very applications driven research so I'm
going to go ahead and start by telling
you a little bit about the applications
that we've worked on so this is a system
for locating animals based on the sounds
that they make and we've used it for a
variety of bird species but the critter
in the upper left there is a marmot a
large rodent native to the southwest the
United States I don't know if you get
them up here in the northwest anybody
seen marmots and Seattle okay around see
how excellent well marmots unlike most
rodents that you may be familiar with
make very loud sounds when they're
scared so this is a marmot alarm call
something like that and they and they
make one of these alarm calls whenever
they're frightened by a predator or in
our case for testing purposes by a
graduate student charging at them and
based on those sounds that they make we
can we can locate them using a
microphone array so the platform that we
used in this deployment was our
prototype Vox net platform this is an
embedded Linux based platform with the
arm microcontroller that where each node
has a fixed array of four microphones on
top of it and there's a low-power mica
to mote that can duty cycle the more
powerful components in the system and we
deploy the eight of these nodes
throughout a meadow riddled with Marmot
burrows in gothic colorado in august two
thousand seven so this was the
deployment that i did with the lab mate
from MIT as well as with some people
from UCLA biology so this is a
relatively high data rate embedded
sensing application this gives you a
little bit of a sense for the kinds of
things that we're working on we've also
used wave scope in the context of
several other applications in our lab in
collaboration with with different groups
so in addition to locating marmots we've
worked on
on pothole detection using fleet of
taxis that are equipped with our sensor
packages that have accelerometer and GPS
and we use this to build a map of the of
the worst potholes in the Boston area
although if any of you have been to
Boston the more well posed problem might
be detecting non potholes and we've also
worked on some computer vision
applications in this one in California
using using camera sensor networks as
well as pipeline leak detection in water
pipelines using vibrational sensors
we've done some speaker detection and
speaker identification using any
embedded device that has a microphone
such as a cell phone and finally we've
done some EEG seizure onset detection
using 22 channels of EEG data that come
from leads on the head and go to an
embedded device now today I'm going to
use all three of these applications in
the context of doing an evaluation so
just bear those in mind a little bit and
the relevant features of these
applications they want you to take away
here are that each of them has a
processing structure that can be
expressed as a collection of independent
tasks communicating via data streams so
I'm going to go ahead and call that a
data flow graph and we'll be talking
about data flow graphs a lot and
somewhat uniquely to these embedded
sensing domains we see a combination of
very regular processing often near the
sensor inputs where audio or video data
is streaming in with very irregular
processing because you detect a marmot
event drag a triggered computation and
one of the key challenges in doing this
range of applications is dealing with
all the heterogeneous hardware and
software platforms that are involved and
that heterogeneity starts with the
software environments so in one of these
embedded sensing applications will
typically have at least three different
platforms involved will have very low
power sensors will have a base station
typically a laptop or a desktop
something that's on the on the server
side or back end where the data is
feeding to over here and then will
typically have something in the middle
often a microserver such as the vox net
platform i showed you or a smartphone
with capabilities somewhere in the
middle now these are programmed using
totally disjoint software environments
of course we have all our usual
languages and tools that we use on our
desktop and we have a different set of
SDKs and environments and tools that we
use for programming or smartphones
nowadays
and then we have yet another set of
operating systems languages and tools
that we use on our low power embedded
devices and so this is a big mass if i
want to write a piece of software that
targets all of these components i have a
lot of work ahead of me partially
because of the software heterogeneity
and programming models for sensor
networks has been an active area of
research for the last several years
because it's recognized to be a
difficult problem and a lot of the work
in this area has focused on has focused
on capturing communication idioms in
large networks of these low power
devices including some of my own
previous work on the regiment system so
but none of these systems were broadly
portable across different classes of
devices until the wave script system
that I'm talking to you talking about
today and the goals of this of the wave
script system are threefold so as with
many of these other efforts we want to
bring higher level features to very
small platforms we want to make it
easier to program these devices but we
also want to pay close attention to the
life cycle in doing one of the kinds of
applications that we're working on so
first you have to somehow prototype your
application perhaps in MATLAB prototype
the algorithm assess the hardware
requirements pick a platform buy it and
implement your implement your system and
then later on down the road if the
hardware gets upgraded you might be able
to change the application if the
application requirements change you
might need to change the hardware so
addressing these lifecycle issues it
requires a somewhat different focus on
the tools and one of the implications of
this is that it needs to be very easy to
move computation around between
different parts of this picture and
that's a requirement of our system the
computation is easily my gradable
between these heterogeneous platforms so
given that motivation the rest of the
talk is going to look like this first
I'm going to be talking about the
high-level wave scope design and then in
the second part of the talk I'm going to
put on my compilers hat and we're going
to talk about optimizing software that's
written for this kind of environment and
in the third part we're going to talk
about the deeper problem of
automatically partitioning applications
across different kinds of devices okay
so a bit of background parallel models
of computation have been around for a
long time obviously and in particular
languages and compilers that have
extensions for streaming or four
parallel processing are also quite old
so a lot of these earlier systems were
quite
in general but also had some
disadvantages which is why we're still
working on this problem today so a lot
of these systems were unsuitable for
static analysis and made it very
difficult to leverage domain-specific
optimizations such as in the domain of
digital signal processing and this made
it hard to extract scalable parallel
performance so recently there's been a
lot of focus on stream programming in
the last few years and a lot of this
renewed interest has come from a systems
in architecture community specifically
with the focus on parallel performance
so we see systems like these for example
frequently motivated by particular
parallel architectures that people want
to program the streamit system is a
synchronous dataflow based streaming
language that came along with tiled
architectures like raw and the brook
language was around for programming GPUs
but at the same time a different
community was focusing on the on the
problem with streaming and that was the
database community and they came up with
systems like Aurora and Stanford stream
and they were interested in a different
set of applications of financial
applications for example where data
rates are irregular and you stock ticks
and what have you and so they picked up
an asynchronous data flow model instead
and likewise the literature in this area
is focused largely on dynamic
optimization and dynamic scheduling
rather than static scheduling an
optimization that is appropriate to a
synchronous dataflow model such as you
see in digital signal processing or
graphics applications where the data
rates on all the edges and one of these
data flow graphs are known now there are
advantages to both of these sets of
systems so on the top here the the
synchronous dataflow systems can be
extremely fast and they can exert and
they can exhibit great parallel speed
ups on a variety of different
architectures whereas these a
synchronous dataflow based systems we
see in the database stream processing
world offer a great degree of
flexibility in the kinds of applications
that they can handle so we actually
tried starting off prototyping some of
the sensing applications that we worked
on using these different systems in
particular Aurora and stream it but for
various reasons we ran into problems and
we ended up needing to build our own and
their wave scope was born and part of
the goal of wave scope was to combine
some of the desirable tributes of these
different of these different approaches
and in particular wave scope takes a
very profile driven empirical approach
to scheduling and dividing data flow
graphs
we're going to pump sample data through
through a data flow graph and observe
when the data rates are regular and then
we can leverage techniques from this
Community otherwise fall back to more
dynamic techniques all right so just to
give you a little not going to belabor
the syntax here but just to give you a
little bit of a sense of what it's like
to program with wave scope there's one
important keyword that I need to tell
you about and that's iterate so iterate
is a for each statement over a stream so
a stream is a ordered ordered sequence
of values that are going to appear at
some time and we want to assign a name
to every to every value in the stream
and when this introduces a single data
flow operator in our data flow graph
that we're constructing with one input
and one output when an element becomes
available on the on the input stream we
execute a block of code that goes inside
those curly braces so this is a very
simple example here Amit is going to
send output on the output channel so all
this does is take a number on the input
and if it's even emit two copies of it
otherwise I met one copy of it so for
example if we get a four will fire and
admit two fours on the output and the
return value of one of these iterate
statements is just a stream itself so we
can assign a name to it defining the
stream s2 in terms of the stream s and
we can use it anywhere in the program
that we like we can define functions
that take streams input and return
streams as output they build with
iterate and we could we could run a loop
like this that will accumulate a chain
of dataflow operators that would look
something like that okay so switching
from the source model to the execution
model once we have one of these data
flow graphs how does it execute at
runtime well there are lots of different
different choices in terms of picking a
data flow model i mentioned that we're
going to have an asynchronous data flow
model in particular a non-deterministic
a synchronous dataflow model and let me
show you what that means so here's our
data flow operator introduced via and
iterate that was our example iterate
from the previous slide the dataflow
operator has some code inside it
visualized by those lines and when an
element becomes available we have to
fire atomically execute for some length
of time and produce zero or more outputs
on our output Channel and so you could
think of this as an event or an
interrupt there's no there's no back
pressure here that must be handled when
the event occurs and when the scheduler
decides to invoke the dataflow operator
so the out
here s 2 is a value that can be consumed
in multiple places and that gives us fan
out in the model first let me tell you
about state fulness so these data flow
operators can be stateful they
optionally can have private state that
they maintained between invocations but
the the rule here for this for this
particular model is that there's no
shared state so it's not allowed for
another data flow operator to touch that
same state that's prohibited by the
model offering on individual input data
yes that's right do can specify like a
fire after my hundred of them so that
would be so that's an example of a
simple optimization if you were taking
very fine-grained inputs you would want
the implementation to only invoked every
100 yes I can mommy or do anything we'll
get fire yes that's right that's right
so you don't have any particular control
over the channel that's coming in the
API is simply when you it's a 4h type
model it's a loop and for every element
you're running one iteration of the loop
okay so as I started to say we get fan
out by consuming s2 in multiple places
at multiple downstream operators that's
fine now to tell you I need to tell you
about one more primitive operator in the
system that gives us fan in and that's
merge so merge takes two streams input
and inner leaves them in the real time
order that they arrive and so that makes
it a non-deterministic merge and that's
what makes our data flow model a
non-deterministic data flow model so
these two primitive operators are what
everything in the system is built in
terms of and i'll tell you about more
complex synchronization policies for
example between two different streams
and those are built up using merges and
iterates that's the real core
abstraction so this system i'm talking
about deals in terms of data flow graphs
an application is a complete data
photograph with a fixed set of
connections and we can think of each one
of these operators as containing some
code in a portable intermediate language
that can retarget to all the different
devices we're interested in programming
so the system architecture here consists
of back-end code generators that can
target each of these different classes
of devices that we're interested in so
ultimately the application needs to be
split up into disjoint sub graphs
our then assigned to particular devices
and a back-end code generator will John
yes for all these so you say it's a
fixed set of operating for a set of
operators right so does that is that
just something that compiler enforces
where a few written code that has some
kind of conditional around whether and
then hidden within that is whether an
operator gets created then it arps there
and says you can't do that yes well you
just can't construct something like that
there's no api provided for adding or
removing operators at runtime the kind
of extreme if we put up synchronous
dataflow on one end the other extreme
would be some of these models in
particularly these for the streaming
databases allow you to dynamically
change the data data flow graph or
something like Erlang where the set of
actors and the messaging relationships
are totally dynamic so in this we we
still have a lot of information about
what the actors are and how and who's
communicating to who but we don't know
necessarily what the data rates are so
we were taking we've taken two small
steps away from sacred as data flow you
choose not into mr. sister Patti okay
sure sure so certainly determinism is a
nice property when you can keep it and
that's one of the primary advantages of
synchronous dataflow but in this case
the merge I showed you it merges things
in real time so frequently you want to
do a sort of select statement over to
real-time source of sources of events
you don't statically have any knowledge
over which one's going to happen first
you might want to call this in
deterministic instead of non
deterministic if you're familiar with
that distinction yes you could make a
deterministic model in terms of
timestamps yeah it does we found that it
didn't it doesn't help us and it's not
assumed that all the that we have time
stamps in a single global clock for all
the different tokens in the system
because of course we are operating in
distributed environments and time sink
is is another issue but I'd be happy to
get into a little more detail on that
offline okay so I wanted to give you a
little bit of an idea of what's involved
and trying to target one of these small
platforms so the smallest platforms that
we target are these tiny OS nodes and
these are small indeed with a tour
16-bit microcontrollers with 22 10k of
RAM and with no memory protection in the
operating system tiny OS is a common one
and no thread supports so none of the
features that make programming easier
that we're all familiar with and there's
of course spent a lot of research and
trying to get some of these features
back into these small platforms like the
work on pro two threads and also like
what I'm going to show you on this slide
so in this slide I'm going to address
how we target our abstract data flow
model to this very small platform
addressing both data granularity and
computation granularity so first in the
wave scope model one of these data flow
operators can win it fires it can take a
data structure in and execute for an
arbitrary length of time and produce
some arbitrarily complex data flow or
data structures on the output side so in
particular on the tiny west side if this
if this data element here is going to
need to travel over a radio edge it's
going to need to be serialized and split
up into different message size chunks so
that's all well and good and can be
demonstrate forward techniques it helps
the tiny OS programmer to not need to
worry about that serialization or D
serialization but there's nothing
particularly interesting or problematic
about it the more complex issue is
dealing with the granularity of
mutation so one of these data flow
operators when it fires it can it
essentially execute an arbitrary program
inside and it can run for an arbitrary
length of time in the tiny westworld I
mentioned we don't have threads instead
the execution model is that we have tap
a tiny OS tasks and one task can run at
a time exclusively on the system runs
until completion and can post other
tasks through a global cue so what we
need to do is we could try to execute an
operator as a single task but it would
run for too long and starve out system
tasks that provide important services
like maintaining routing trees and the
wireless network and what have you so we
need to have some way of splitting these
tasks up into bite-sized pieces that are
appropriate for tiny eyes tasks and the
approach that we use for this could be
called profile driven cooperative
multitasking so what we do is we use our
very fine-grained profile information to
profile and iterate operator like this
with with a piece of code inside it and
understand the structure of its dynamic
extent in terms of which parts of the
code are contributing to its runtime now
in these sensing applications typically
we can assume that they're doing when
they do execute they're running a fairly
regular pattern of execution so we've
strapped elate from the profiling
results that if we want to divide one of
these tasks up in the following places
we can map those dynamic locations back
on to locations in the code where we can
insert yield statements including
yielding at particular iterations of
loops so once we have that the compiler
can generate separate tasks that run up
until a yield and then repost the
remainder of the computation and so
that's how we address granularity for
for computation on tiny Mouse to give
you a sense of the problems involved
okay so returning to this picture to
finish finish the system architecture
here just having this data flow graph
abstraction for programming some of
these very small devices like tiny OS
nodes is a big improvement but we didn't
stop there for two reasons and one of
them is that these graphs can get quite
large so you can imagine very large yet
very regular graphs that you would
instead want to write a program to
construct and that's exactly what we do
here the kind of source programs that I
showed you earlier are actually programs
that construct grafts so that's what a
high-level wave scope program would be
and the wave scope compiler up here the
compiler front end which is shared
between all these different backends it
accepts sample profiling data in which
it uses
to drive all of its decisions about
optimization and about partitioning data
flow graphs now the second reason that
we've introduced this what I would call
a multi-stage programming model where we
write a program that's generating
another program in the form of a data
flow graph is that we actually want to
have an asymmetry here where we have a
different feature set in the compile
time language and in the runtime
language and the reason for that is that
we want to have an extremely simple
runtime language both because we want it
to be easily portable when we add new
platforms and because on some of these
small platforms you might not want to
pay the price for some of these
interesting features that you might want
to have in a high-level source language
like higher order functions or
extensible records so I call this
asymmetric multi-stage programming
because the different stages are in
different languages with different
feature sets and you see this all over
the place especially in domain-specific
languages for for hardware design as a
common place where this multistage
architecture pops up blue speck is an
example of a hardware design language
that employs it but also we write
programs that generate other programs in
all kinds of different situations the c
preprocessor is a simple example and
java programs generate SQL queries all
the time now in terms of the my
contributions to the system architecture
that i brought up here i'm responsible
for the entire software stack here and
other people in my group service clients
of the wave scope system using it in
some of the different applications that
i showed you but i myself have also done
a lot of the application development
okay so zooming in here on the compiler
it can put it's composed of a number of
stages that we're going to talk about
today in particular these four and the
first step here WS eval is going to take
a source program and evaluated to get
out the data flow graph the rest of the
compiler deals in terms of data flow
graphs and optimizing them so first the
ws eval step so the goal of WS eval is
to take one of these abstract source
programs that constructs a data flow
graph so for example here's a function f
that takes a stream as input and
produces a stream as output and here's
two indications of the function f we
essentially want to evaluate this
program and and come up with something
like this so this is a textual
representation of a data flow graph here
it's a fixed data flow graph in the
sense that every place where you see the
word iterate it corresponds directly to
a node in a fixed data flow graph so the
goal is to go from here to here what
interesting about our approach our
multi-state programming designs were
essentially generating we're generating
the runtime program from the compile
time program you might call this partial
evaluation metaprogramming multistage
programming because of the structure of
our particular application domain we've
managed to come up with a multi-stage
design here that's rather unobtrusive
and avoids any quotation and unquote
ation in constructing these code objects
that are going to run at runtime and the
way that we end up doing the actual
evaluation in the ws eval step is we run
a simple interpreter that's that has a
value representation extended to include
stream values a stream value is going to
correspond to either an iterator or
emerge and the main of the program if
you will returns a stream value so
that's a complete application and once
we run our interpreter and we have a
stream value in memory then the final
step is to unpack it back into code to
get something like this and that's our
that's our multi-stage programming
approach sure sure so some of those so
some of the features that we have up
here are well in particular in the in
the in the language up here we can wire
data flow graphs the data flow graph is
kind of still in flux but the data flow
graph has been fixed by the time here by
the time we get to here and if you look
at the particular code that goes inside
inside one of these Arians this simple
mental model here for programmers by the
way is that everything outside of an
iterate is going to go away at compile
time and everything inside and iterate
is going to be a dataflow kernel that
executes the runtime so the question is
what are the language features that you
can use inside that data flow colonel so
we use a type system to kind of separate
these different layers here and make
sure that you only use allowed features
inside inside the iterates the basic
language model is the same in terms of
the data model and you can reuse a
function either inside and iterate or
outside and iterate so that's fine but
in terms of some of the particular
features i mentioned higher-order
functions and extensible records for
example we have those in the in the
metal language but they have to go away
in the compile time language but they
have to go away in the runtime language
so those are two examples and I could
talk about it in more depth offline or
at the end okay so the second step in
the second stage of the talk here as I
mention I'm putting on my compiler and
optimization hat
and and we're going to be talking a
little bit about the Marmot deployment
some more that's me looking for marmots
so it's a new language right yes it is
so a lot of what I'm showing you are set
of tools that work with data flow graphs
and are somewhat agnostic to what's
inside them but we've also gone and made
a domain-specific language for writing
these streaming applications because we
feel that we can do more that way and we
contend over the message comes does it
have some 18 old engine noises be
ashamed of this message so how can I
determine these comes from the same
somewhere in fuel train in this place
sure so for example if you had some
point in the graph where you at high-end
agree and you want to know what the
origin of the different messages are
well you well you would have to tag them
yourself because the basic computational
model doesn't have that built-in of
course it would be very easy for you to
do so so for example went that merge
that I showed you it doesn't change it
doesn't change anything in terms of the
data that it passes through but you can
tag the tuples that are flowing through
ahead of time so that you know which one
they originated from one places is very
relevant is when you're dealing with the
sensor network like this you very often
want to put the note ID into the record
that you're sending along didn't I would
guess ID right so they know the old
note sure you could yeah absolutely so
the by the way compared to a lot of
other stream programming languages like
stream it the data flow model is pretty
rich here so with this is a high-level
type-safe garbage collected language you
can have lists you can have a raise you
can have records that are passed these
data objects so that a passing these
tokens that go through the data flow
graph so by all means build whatever
data structure you like within the data
that you're passing along that can
record whatever you want sensation mean
I would fill empty nice venue with each
of the event has some properties I would
publish optimized but now we just I
couldn't do anything pertaining to talk
so that's excellent point is that
there's a tension here where if you bake
more into the model itself you might you
might expose more information at the
compiler that it could use for
optimizations but of course then you've
complicated the design by baking in
particular features into the into the
into the data flow model that might not
be exactly what some future user wants
so we've gone for a very simple core
model and actually I'm going to address
exactly that point when we talk about
domain-specific optimization so there
are particular domain specific
optimizations we want to capture but we
don't want to commit our compiler to
them in the sense of baking them in
directly to our implementation for a
variety of different engineering reasons
so I will get to that actually right now
so the step right after WSC val is that
we apply algebra we use an optimization
system based on algebraic rewrite rules
so these pop up in various places in
some general purpose compilers and also
in some database systems so a rewrite
rules are simply statements to the pro
that the end user or more likely the
library writer can put in their code
that say when i see a pattern on the
left when I match the pattern on the
Left I want to replace it with an
expression on the right so for example F
of T of inverse fft of X should just be
rerun to X if we're dealing with
windowed streams streams of a data
structures essentially re windowing
change the window granularity twice is
redundant so you only take the second
one those are to rewrite rules that are
in our libraries so you might you might
immediately notice a problem here which
is
as based on what I've told you so far WS
eval is going to spit out a data flow
graph consisting only these iterative
merge notes so essentially an anonymous
data flow graph there's no notion of REE
window in that data flow graph there's
just a bunch of black boxes with compute
inside them so that we have a bit of
attention here in terms of where we do
these algebraic rewrite rules and the
way that we've solved this problem is
that WS eval is run twice so in
particular the first time through we
want to leave any any names that are
mentioned in these algebraic rewrite
rules we leave them abstract and that
enables us to reduce the program as far
as possible possibly bring these to read
windows together from distant points in
the live in different libraries that
they originated but without reducing the
program so far essentially without
inlining the definition of rhe window to
actually generate a series of iterates
so then once we've done that first wsd
value we execute our rewrite rules until
fixation until they're no more we
greedily run all the rewrite rules we
can and then we go back and do w SE
valla second time which actually gets us
down to a plane anonymous data flow
graph of black boxes and all the
subsequent steps the compiler deal only
with that data flow graph representation
I remember from the fftw work was having
rewrite rules that were not necessarily
improvements and then wanted to do a
search at the end is that something that
is you know what are your thoughts on
that sure so these are absolutely not
the most sophisticated kinds of
optimizations that we could apply this
has worked well for us and it's been a
way to capture some domain properties in
an extensible way that we apply to
different domains but it's certainly you
you might say these are only we can only
capture a small class of interesting
domain properties in this way certainly
a system like that where you had a more
interesting control policy for applying
rewrite rules would be one way of
generalizing this but for us the main
thing was to see how far we could get
with this to try to encode domain
optimizations for complex event
processing for digital signal processing
without having to make them into our
core compiler this was 11 relatively
straightforward way of doing so and in
particular we didn't do this just to
catch opportunities for optimization in
existing programs it's not just a
speed-up program
we also find the algebraic rewrite rules
are very useful for enabling better
library design and one example of this
is if you're trying to design a digital
signal processing library then it's a
cognitive burden on the user to have a
mix of different functions in frequency
domain as well as in time domain so
wouldn't it be nice if we could write
our libraries so that everything is
simply in time domain but of course that
would be crazy because then the user
would compose two black box library
functions a and B and they would turn
out to both internally prefer to operate
let's say in frequency domain but just
convert back to time domain for the
purpose of communicating between them
but if we can count on our system to do
some of these basic algebraic
optimizations like eliminating this I of
T and F of T then we can write our
libraries in this way and enable simpler
interfaces than we would otherwise be
able to and this is for example what
we've done with our DSP libraries back
well there are no actor batteries so
that was part of the point is that you
Numerical libraries nothing to do with
the actors
ah so well I'm not sure I caught that
question black box hey factor hostages
black box was not an answer yeah yeah so
I'm sorry and that's actually good point
of this slide is it looks like these our
actors decomposing into smaller actors
but yeah this was just a visualization
be helpful so what you'd actually have
is is is you have expressions in the
original source language things like
real window of stream its expression
that is a function that is going to it
when it's in line will introduce a bunch
of iterates which themselves correspond
to actors once we get down to just the
actor model the data flow model then we
just have a bunch of anonymous data flow
operator and we can't do any algebraic
rewrite rules at that point so we have
to catch them before that before we get
to that point okay so once we do get
ourselves down to just the data flow
graph then the next important step is to
profile it as I mentioned so every set
every data source in the program is
associated with some data sample now
it's typical in this embedded sensing
domain that a first step will always be
to go out to the field and capture some
raw data so that you can even formulate
your experiments in test your algorithm
for example in our environment
application we have a terabyte of marvin
audio data on a server that we use for
testing and there are more ergonomic
ways to do this probably but currently
we simply have a kind of a macro switch
in the the that you use in the source
code to specify for every input source
where you'll get a sample data file if
you're not using the raw sensor source
itself so when we do the profiling step
the goal is to pump this sample data
through the data flow graph and make
observations about the data rates that
we see on the edges and the execution
times for the nodes themselves so that's
important information about the data
flow graph based on the profiling data
but there's a separate step that the
user also has to do just in time as
they're about to as they're about to do
their deployment on a wireless network
and that's to profile the network
channel capacity in the deployment
environment so for one of these mesh
networks the actual band was that we can
get out depends on a number of
conditions so you run a portable wave
scope program that characterizes the
channel capacity and gives you basically
a per node maximum send rate that we're
going to use to formulate the
optimization problems that I'm going to
talk about alright so this profiling
data is going to drive all the
subsequent optimization
system as very simple example of this
would be the batching optimization that
that gia mentioned earlier which is if
we notice that an operator is
lightweight in the sense that it runs
quickly and that it's receiving a high
frequency of small data items as input
then regardless of what platform are
running on it's going to help to batch
together those elements for bulk
processing and we get some speed up for
that whether we're in a single threaded
or multi-threaded context so now I'm
going to switch back to the Marmot
application talk a little bit and
evaluate the system developed by
profiling network is a robust step what
sure sure so I will happily confess that
our system presently does a lot of
offline optimization so you could what
you might very well worry about
dynamically changing conditions and
currently we don't have a good way to
Rio mais a given deployment now it
happens to be the case that when we do
these deployment and remote areas we
don't have to worry about you know 802
11 interference or or what-have-you so
it's a little bit more it's reasonable
in our case to just profile the network
once make some assumptions about the
stability of those measurements and then
base our optimization decisions on that
but certainly future work would include
looking at more adaptive adaptive
mechanisms as simple one being simply
rerunning the whole thing every 30
seconds 60 seconds what have you okay so
back to marmots the Marmot a
localization application consists of
three steps the first one is that we're
going to listen continuously one of
those for audio channels on a given node
for a sound that might be a marmot call
and basically this just means a spike of
energy and a certain frequency of the
band that penetrates our adaptive
threshold so then we've got a marmot
detection event that happens during a
certain time range we want to
synchronize the audio from all four
microphone channels on that local to
that node and packaged up together the
snippets that from that time window
where there is a detection given that
information those four snippets we can
do a direction of arrival search through
possible angles of arrival for the sound
that's going to give us a radial
probability map for where the sound
might have come from now there are some
asymmetries that we can't overcome here
so one of these radial probability maps
for a given for an individual node is
going to be sort of multi lobed in that
there are ambiguities but the basic idea
of the application is that when we fuse
the information from
front nodes we have enough information
to figure out where the sound came from
so the end result the third step is to
fuse the information from all the nodes
and come up with a likelihood map where
this is heat map where the color
represents the probability that sound
originated at that point and we'd guess
the animal to have been at the point of
highest likelihood and this pops up on
my screen on my laptop in real time the
field so with modest simplification this
is the data flow graph that corresponds
to that application we've got a raw
audio data coming in we've got our first
step where we detect marmot like sounds
we sink together the four channels of
audio and by the way internally this is
going to be based on those merge
operators and then we do that
directional rival computation I
mentioned and this is a relatively
expensive second step especially when
we're executing on the sensor node
itself it takes about two and a half
seconds and then we send the output
which is simply a small array of
probabilities for that radial
probability map across the network
interface and associated events
temporally and computer pseudo
likelihood map here so one of the first
things we noticed when we were out in
the field for ten days was that the
marmot calls were bursty ER than we
thought and one marmot would chain react
off the others and we would overwhelm
the cpu on the embedded device and lose
data so it helped that we could just
change a line of code because this was
all in a unified system to move that
second step to the server side of the
computation where now we send those four
pieces of synchronized audio over the
network interface and do all the
direction of arrival computations on the
more powerful base station back end okay
so in the still in the single threaded
case talking about the embedded node we
saw a nice speed up in the execution of
our implementation relative to a
previous implementation that a different
group of graduate students had done of a
subset of the system a year earlier so
it was fortunate to have that apples to
apples comparison and there are two
contributors to the performance here
that I'm splitting out as the event
detection itself the operators that I
showed you and the basic data
acquisition overhead so we saw a speed
up in both of these components for two
different reasons the yellow bar here
essentially got smaller do the
optimizations that I mentioned including
batching and the algebraic rewrite
optimizations and the the reason that
the purple bar
smaller's a little bit more subtle so
the C code that the original
implementers here wrote was using a
framework called the M star framework
for for doing embedded sensing
applications and the M star framework
provides a lot of flexibility to the
user except it does so in the form of
runtime services that connect it that
exists in separate processes and connect
together and on this arm platform here
there was a lot of overhead to those
kinds of runtime services so our system
by contrast is a very offline whole
program optimization oriented system
that can smash everything down together
and run it in a single system process
and that greatly reduced the overhead of
our data acquisition itself this is it
the sensor this is the Box name platform
with the four microphones yeah yeah so
it's not as low power as some of the
devices that I'll show you but in this
case it was it was great we wrote less
code we got more performance and it also
had a bit of a practical benefit because
the extra CPU cycles that we freed up
enabled us to implement new tasks in the
field like we implemented a spill to
disk task that archived all the data to
flash memory as well and that was useful
okay so switching from the single
threaded case to the parallel case as I
mentioned earlier the synchronous
dataflow models scale exhibit very nice
parallel performance on a number of
different parallel architectures so here
we're going to look at the intra node
parallelism on say a multi-core and with
our a synchronous dataflow model we can
apply some of the same optimizations
that we see in the synchronous dataflow
world if profiling data gives us enough
information to do so so too common
optimizations for these data flow graphs
are to fuse nodes together fusion and to
recognize stateless operators that we
can split apart for data parallelism so
that is to say if I have a stateless
operator I can make three copies of it
and then I can round robin data elements
stripe them across the different workers
if you will so a great policy for this
these two optimizations in the context
of cigarettes data flow can be seen in a
spa so six and we we've managed to
successfully apply these optimizations
as well in a synchronous dataflow using
our profiling data so here's an example
of that expensive second direction of a
second
step to the Marmot application the
direction of arrival search running on
an SP in this case this was a 4
quad-core Barcelona machine but you
could also imagine running on my laptop
in the field so this is relevant either
when we're processing lots of data
offline for testing or when we're in the
field and using a multi-core base
station so we one thing we see here is
that fission by itself doesn't perform
as well as first doing fusion and then
fish and this is a well-known property
because you don't want to generate a
data flow graph like that if you run
fusion first you'll instead generate
this data flow graph and omit spurious
splits and joins so ultimately what we
see here is that when we're processing
marmot detection what we're doing here
is we're parallelizing the work between
consecutive marmot detection so we're
round-robin the work and consecutive
marble detections two different workers
on different cores and we achieve a
reasonable speed up there but it doesn't
reduce latency of processing an
individual detection at all so I'm going
to tell you a little bit about one more
optimization that our compiler does
which to our knowledge is unique to wave
scope among stream processing systems
and this is an array based kind of huge
efficient where if the compiler can
determine that your operator is
producing an array as output and an
example of that is that direction of
arrival computation that produces an
array of probabilities then we can split
it up into a number of workers that take
the same input and produce a sub
segments of the array which can then be
stitched back together to produce the
original produced the original output
and if we apply this if we enable this
optimization or a compiler we see a
speed-up that looks like this so the
important thing to note here is that we
get a nice speed up until about 6 X at
which point it falls off because we're
splitting the array into smaller and
smaller pieces and not deriving any
benefit from it but at this point here
we achieved 6x improvement in both
throughput and latency which is relevant
if we're processing a real time on the
field and also it's worth noting that my
laptop doesn't have more than six
processors already so this is the
appropriate form of optimization now in
the present implementation the this
array fission optimization precludes the
normal of the application of normal
fission now if our compiler did a little
bit more work and would re profile
different configurations of the graph
rather than just running profiling once
it might
able to find out where that local Optima
was and apply this optimization in
moderation the ideal thing to do here
would be to apply normal fission in and
then subsequently apply a ray based
vision in concert so that we would end
up producing individual data elements as
sub segments stitching them together and
then interleaving them and that would
give us the best of both worlds here and
would be the right thing to do ok so now
I've talked about the single the single
threaded context I've talked about
parallels I'm inside a given device and
finally I want to go ahead and talk
about the distributed context between
different devices so i'm going to show
you our initial solution for program
partitioning for automatically dividing
data photographs between different
platforms ok so back to one of these
data flow graphs typically the input
sudan flow graph our sensors on an
embedded device and the outputs go
either to a database or the user on some
back-end base station and the goal of
the partitioning step here is to assign
all the operators to one platform the
other which induces a cut that has to go
where the edges have to go across the
network boundary and given one of these
partitions data flow graph data flow
graphs we expect the compiler and tool
chain to be able to produce a binary for
each platform and disseminate the
appropriate sub graph to it now in a
sensor network type deployment we have n
nodes rather than just one so we can
replicate that portion of the sub graph
across all those nodes and for the rest
of this talk let's just assume we use
the same partitioning but we could use
different partitions at different nodes
by running the producer multiple times
now the fact that we've replicated a sub
graph of our data flow graph here has
interesting implications when some of
these operators are stateful and you can
ask me about that offline or I can refer
you to the paper for that tricky bit ok
so the way we formulate the partitioning
problem here is that given our profiling
data we essentially have weights on our
edges and on our nodes our edges and our
vertices that correspond to CPU cost to
compute cost and to bandwidth on the
edges so there are two relevant numbers
here for a particular cut one of them is
the sum of the CPU cost on the embedded
note and the other one is the sum of
network costs on the edges that are cut
now we can also look at the sum of the
load on the server side but for our
applications the server is effectively
infinite capacity relative to the
embedded node so we don't worry about it
for this optimization problem all right
so this isn't it the graph minimum cut
graph partitioning in general is np-hard
and we have formulated the solution of
this problem as an integer linear
program also an also an np-hard problem
and our formulation goes something like
this well an integer linear program is a
collection of equalities and
inequalities over certain variables here
we introduce a set of variables
corresponding to each vertex in the
graph that are going to take on a value
of zero or one depending on whether or
not that operator is assigned to the
censored platform or the back end we
also introduced the set of variables for
the edges that are going to correspond
to 0 or 1 based on whether or not it's a
cut edge and then our goal is to enforce
resource bounds where we say that the
sum of CPU usage across all the
operators that are assigned to the
embedded node must not exceed some cap
on cpu usage similarly we restrict
network usage such that the sum of of
network usage across cut edges must not
exceed some cap in weighted by all that
profiling data that we gathered and
finally our objective function that
we're minimizing here is going to be a
linear combination of CPU usage and
network usage so we're enforcing
resource bounds and minimizing some
combination of resource of those two
resource usages now this is all it's
very straightforward the only tricky bit
here is how you relate these F and G
variables while keeping the problem
linear rather than quadratic and for
that I can refer you to the paper so it
looks like there are three parameters
here there's see in an alpha now c is
typically one because these compute
measurements are measured as a fraction
of the capability capacity of the device
that you're profiling on and we profile
on all the embedded devices that we're
interested in using the network capacity
in here is set by that network channel
characterization tool that i mentioned
and finally alpha here could be set by
the user as a way of trading off their
their optimization priorities for
compute usage versus radio but typically
this linear combination here serves as a
proxy for energy usage in which case you
can set alpha empirically based on
measurements of the energy cost of the
CPU versus the radio
hi this is for each individual node yeah
so by the way I'm assuming a relatively
simple for this partitioning problem i'm
assuming a simple communication
organization where all nodes are
communicating to the server and i'm not
taking into account yes i'm not modeling
the the uneven energy usage that results
from from the malting out network so
that's just not something that we're
modeling but it's important an important
point okay so to evaluate this go ahead
and when you said I'm looking at the
minimum over all notes are you saying
then that this is like minimum Max is
this a minimum maximum energy usage oh
no no so this is basically this
partitioning algorithm is figuring out
what's going to happen between a given
embedded node and a service in yeah and
we're just trying to minimize that that
pressure to the data flow graph and it's
and then a simple thing to do is to take
that partition that partition and use it
on on every note but you could do more
complex things as well okay so for the
evaluation here we take a collection of
different embedded devices that we're
interested in programming including the
little micro server that I showed you
before and our low-power embedded notes
that we've extended here with a custom
audio board for doing the speaker
detection application that I'll tell you
about in a second and we've got our
smartphones and we see a different mix
of sort of CPU power and radio power
here changing the optimization criteria
and finally here's an example of a
Meraki outdoor base station which has a
very weak CPU in a strong radio so given
those platforms we take a couple of our
applications here our human speech
detection and identification application
which has a very simple processing
structure a linear pipeline of operators
that's going to put that it's going to
pop up in the evaluation the next couple
slides and we also took another one of
our applications the opposite end of the
spectrum in terms of complexity our EEG
application is 1400 operators in a
relatively large data flow graph
applying a cascade of filters to each
one of the 22 channels okay yeah after
your profiler spit out or is it is that
is that the closer to what the source of
it
ah so this is after the after the
profile this is the actual data
photograph yeah yeah yes so by the way
the source code is relatively simple
this is a this is that there's less
source code in this application than
there is in this application and by the
way this is the this is the kind of
visualization the compiler spits out
using graph is it's a this is the
profiling data in terms of the colors of
the of the different operators so we can
also look at the the network vs cpu
usage signature of a given application
this is the speaker detection
application laid out with its linear
pipeline of operators laid out across
the x-axis here and so we look at the
cumulative CPU usage in red as we push
more computation down into the embedded
node and at the same time we look at the
band width of that single edge that
needs to be cut as we're splitting this
data flow graph so it's a linear
pipeline it's very easy to think about
the space of different partitions here
now we can immediately see that well
like most of these sensing applications
the general trend is towards data
reduction we're taking large data
volumes the input we're extracting
features applying compression and
somehow or another restricting the
volume of data but of course this is not
a monotonic progression we can
immediately we can see here the F of T
for example in this particular
application keeps around both the
frequency and time domain so it
increases the volume of data at the
expense of spending some compute as well
so it wouldn't make a lot of sense to
cut this application right after F of T
right so we can see by eyeballing this
that there are only a few reasonable cut
points basically send across the raw
data over the network or do enough
compute that you can get to filter Bank
here and have actually reduced the data
a significant amount okay so that's what
we can see just by eyeballing now if we
run our partitioning algorithm the many
many times to generate a landscape of
optimal partitions we can get something
that looks like this so this is for a
single channel of the EEG data flow
graph applicant of the the EEG
application here a single channel of
this applique of this graph has about 80
operators in it and what i'm doing here
is an essentially changing that c
parameter if you remember the ILP
formulation so trust me for now that
changing the compute on the embedded
note is equivalent to changing the data
rate at the inputs because for these
applications data rate scales linearly
with with compute costs so what we're
doing here is we're looking at different
hypothetical data rates
how would this application partition if
we change the input data rate to the
application so if we're running at a low
data rate we see that we can fit all the
operators down inside the embedded node
but as the data rate increases I only
show to platforms here as the data rate
increases the amount of compute that we
can afford to do in the embedded node
drops off and the reason we see it drop
off somewhat continuously here rather
than just fall right off a cliff is that
there are multiple points within this
cascade of filters where the data volume
is reduced so you can go part way down
one of these processing paths and get a
partial data reduction for a partial
compute effort yeah oh it does it does
yes so I forgot to mention for this
graph I in the in the objective function
I'm setting alpha 2 i'm setting alpha 20
so I'm minimizing I'm just capping CPU
and minimizing network usage that's the
goal for now for this slide Oh another
question we're doing the robot house
with a high bar or after you do the
George machine just go
instance if you are about the several
data on the server right but if you want
to do the SSD locally then after you
switch to the higher note then there's
no reason to come back right right so
big always one switch port then you want
to find out right that would simplify
but it's not always the case and and I'm
lucky to have a whiteboard right here
one simple reason why that wouldn't
always be the case is if you have two
data paths that are coming together you
have a merge point and one of them is
very expensive but the other one
involves data that's local to the sensor
code so i might want to export this
expensive operator off to the server and
then have the date as its output come
back to be merged with some locally
produced results on the sensor so in
general we might want to go back and
forth but certainly there are a lot of
applications that do meet the constraint
that you mentioned information on fire
right um well yes with profiling data
you can notice a fresh offline but no
programming protonation for that or is
it a single stretch on the ground funds
super for yourself i know i'm i'm pretty
confident that it is in fact an np-hard
problem what we want to do so one thing
you can think about is with one of these
very large graphs you essentially have
you're doing you could think of this as
been packing or you could think of it as
a graph partitioning we're only
interested in what we're packing on to
the embedded node but we could have a
very large graph with a number of
independent decisions that have to be
made that all affect the compute usage
on the embedded node so it makes it a
rather difficult optimization problem
and as a human being it's difficult to
look at these very large data
photographs and even get a qualitative
sense of how you want to partition so to
give you one example of that with this
big EEG data flow graph when we first
were looking at it and trying to
manually partition it it wasn't at all
clear to me whether or not an optimal
partition of the graph would be
horizontal doing processing on all of
the channels half of the way or vertical
doing processing on some of the channels
all of the way and it turns out to be
vertical you as you increase the CPU cap
you fill up one channel at a time and we
discovered that by running our
partitioning algorithm so this shows
similar similar results for our speaker
detection application except with the
axes flipped here so
on the x axis here we have that handful
of reasonable cut points that I showed
you and the y axis shows the predicted
throughput of the entire application
running at that cut point so and by the
way this is just taking an account CPU
constraints and and not not hard Network
bounce so for all each of these
different applicative these different
platforms we can see that the two
weakest platforms those low power
embedded nodes and our Java based
smartphones cannot keep up with the
native data rate of the application here
which is a horizontal line after the
first cut point so then we're stuck
between a rock and a hard place because
we don't have enough compute to do
everything we need to do on the embedded
node and we don't have enough network
bandwidth to get all the data we want
out of the system so something's going
to have to give and that I think is
where things become really interesting
and making these hard trade-offs and our
system can help with that if we close
the loop in the following way so given
CPU and network bounds our algorithm can
give you an awful partitioning the data
flow graph if it exists and based on one
of those partitions we can estimate the
total throughput of the application so
we close the loop here by doing a binary
search over hypothetical data rates to
find the data rate at which the maximum
possible throughput will be achievable
and in this speaker detection
application that happened to be right
after filter Bank was it was the optimal
point but this is still a prediction
based on all the profiling data that the
system is gathered so the final bit here
to close them to close the loop is to go
back and look at ground truth data now I
notice that I'm actually running out of
time so i might go ahead and refer you
to the paper for this evaluation the
bottom line is that if you take a test
bed of notes and we measure it at every
possible cut point and it turns out up
check we actually sold news you can run
a little bit over google make it
okay okay sure all right well here we go
I will go through the slide in detail so
for the speaker detection application
we've got that linear pipeline we can
evaluate it on a test bed of 20 of these
low power modes arranged in a multi-hop
network and we can see with the total
application through but that is how many
speaker detection events do we get back
to the user for each one of these cut
points and this this graph here shows a
20 mode network compared against a
single mode Network and it's not
normalized based on the number of nodes
we're just looking at the absolute
number of detections per second that we
get that we get through the network back
to the user so what we can see here is
until the very last capsule phase which
is very compute-intensive phase this is
actually a totally network bound problem
so that the one the one mode do as well
or better than the 20 mode network and
when we get to that very last cut point
the 20 mode network is going to have 20
times more small CPUs then the single
boat Network so it'll do quite a bit
better in terms of application
throughput so now if we tease apart the
different contributors to data loss in
the system you can basically lose data
either add a sensor because the CPU was
too busy to pick it up or you can lose
data at the network interface because
the network was too congested to convey
it successfully so if we look at these
two different sources of loss we can see
the percentage of input events that we
pick up at the sensor sources declines
as we push more compute onto the node
where you're not able to compete to keep
up with the compute log so we're running
in a kind of overload situation here
where as the amount of the number of
messages we get through the network the
percentage of messages we get through
the network is very nonlinear here and
increases drastically when we've reduced
the data far enough to the network can
tolerate so what we're interested in is
the product of these two lost factors
which is this blue line here and we can
see that the best empirical cut point
here is right after filter Bank which is
what the model predicted so by the way
you can see that in this case on a very
low power platform we're only even at
the best point here we're only
delivering about ten percent of the
ideal application throughput but in some
applications that's perfectly fine in
this case we have a speaker detection
application that it's in its original
formulation would pole 40 times a second
to listen for a speaker in this case on
one of these low power nodes we can only
pull four times a second which is still
a useful application behavior and one of
the lessons here is that even on this
weakest platform it's important to pick
the right cut point because several
these partitions resulted in no data at
all and the ones that did get some data
back the best one was 20 times better
than the worst of them so so it's
important to pick the right one even
with as simple as a data flow graph as
the speaker detection application okay
so for the rest the evaluation I'll
refer you to the paper and I'll just
wrap up here by zooming back out what
blue Fiat integrating source uh so in
this case it was it was a microphone so
we built that custom audio board that we
attach the telus modes all right so
zooming back out here a little bit i
mentioned heterogeneity both in hardware
and software as one of the barriers to
being able to program these kinds of
distributed applications and I want to
make a few comments about where that
heterogeneity is leading us so first of
all we've all in the last 10 years we've
all gone from having a relatively simple
computing environment around us to
having a veritable personal
heterogeneous cluster of devices our
single core has become a multi-core we
now have programmable GPUs in our
personal computers we a lot of us might
have gaming stations that might have
interesting parallel processors in them
and additional program will GPUs but
perhaps most starkly our cell phones
have become smartphones and those
smartphones already will have a
collection of different arm cores in
them GSP a possibly an image signal
processor and another GPU and these
things are all over the place and in the
future this heterogeneity and
architectures is only going to get more
severe especially as some of these low
power devices into our infrastructure
and our appliances and my vision what I
would like to see happen is rather than
all these components remaining sort of
fixed function and programmed
independently I would like it to be
possible for an application to flexibly
touch many of these separate components
at once which means dealing with many
separate architectures and also there's
heterogeneity on the networking side
such a hypothetical application also has
to deal with communicating both over
incredibly tight links between different
cores on the same chip all the way down
to incredibly weak links
doing these low power radios spanning
what we normally refer to as parallel
and distributed computation now I'm
optimistic about this because I think
that we can make computation much more
flexible and we can build applications
across these heterogeneous architectures
and I think that the way forward will
involve a combination of two things we
want to have high level domain specific
representations of computations and we
also want to get a lot better at
modeling measuring and auto tuning the
implementation of these computations and
you can already see successes of this
dual approach in certain projects I'll
mentioned for example the spiral project
at CMU for DSP type computations that's
a domain where they have high-level
structured representations they know
enough about the search space that they
can effectively autotune to map these
computations on to a wide range of
different architectures ultimately i
think the vision that i'm most inspired
by is that for for whatever reasons in
the future the relationship between a
computation and its physical
instantiation is going to become more
indirect more fluid or liquid now a lot
of people I believe are inspired by this
same vision though they use many
different words two words to describe it
some people talk about programming
clouds others talk about programming
grids some people talk about smart dust
motes or amorphous computing but I think
a lot of the motivations are similar
here and a couple observations i want to
make the small and the large have a lot
in common here in terms of if we look at
our high performance big iron computing
environments versus our low power
embedded environments increasingly we
see things like if you look at the small
processing elements in a parallel
architecture like sell the individual
spe s they don't belong to the normal
memory hierarchy and they have their own
small memories so they start to look a
little more like an embedded device and
similarly it's become some groups i've
heard are looking into are looking into
using more low power processors to build
high-performance computing solutions so
we can find ourselves back in the same
place here with dealing with smaller
resource constrained platforms now a
major axis of variation in these
different systems here is heterogeneity
versus homogenate am on versus a
homogeneous networks but it's at one
point that i want to make
in favor of looking at heterogeneity
seriously is that it's hard to get rid
of it even if you start off with a big
computing infrastructure where all the
nodes have the same capabilities if you
for example dealing with heterogeneous
workloads from many different users you
can all of the sudden find yourself in a
situation where your computing landscape
looks very heterogeneous once again so
how do a genius a header date will
always come back to bite you and in
conclusion the wave scope system here is
taken a small step towards making
computation a little bit more liquid and
the system itself is available and is
used at a handful of places and even if
you don't like the automatic
partitioning the the tools we're dealing
with data flow graphs visualizing and
profiling them are very useful and in
terms of the intellectual contributions
here I've shown you a new algorithm for
partitioning data flow graphs we've
looked at some of the novel multistage
programming architecture of this system
and I've talked a little bit about some
of the innovations in the back ends to
be able to target very small devices
thank you and I'd be happy to take any
questions hi back oh yes that's right
that's right good point